Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Daniel Lubetzky, the founder
of the groundbreaking
snack company Kind,
returns to the Tank.
Do you have that ability
to be resourceful?
[ Sniffing ]
To be a hungry hunter?
What I need to know is,
are you gonna hustle?
I've drained
my finances.
Eeh, Chihuahua, caramba!
Listen, listen, listen.
You haven't sold any yet!
We don't care.
Sharks: Ohh!
‐I'll make you an offer.
‐Are you nuts?
Guys, you have no reason
to be desperate.
No, no, no.
Hang on a sec, Mark.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a customized version
of a bedtime essential.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Susana.
I'm Kevin.
And we're seeking
$400,000
for a 5% equity stake
in our company, Pluto Pillow.
Now, I know what
you're all thinking ‐‐
another pillow company?
Well, yes, but thankfully,
here at Pluto,
we do things
differently.
See, finding the perfect pillow
can be so amazing,
but finding
the right pillow for you
can also be super hard.
Here's how it
usually goes ‐‐
while shopping online,
you're faced with an
overwhelming number of options
that can be hard
to compare with one another,
and with tens of thousands
of search results,
how do you know which
would work best for you?
In stores, is it better to
squeeze pillows with your hands,
or should you awkwardly
place your head
on the dirty
display pillows?
The answer is
both suck.
Well, with Pluto,
there's a better way.
Pluto is a custom
pillow company
that custom‐builds
pillows to you
based on your body stats,
how you sleep,
and what you like.
Here's how it works.
Simply visit our website,
fill out
a quick questionnaire,
tell us about
your current pillow,
what you like,
what you didn't like about it,
then answer a few questions
about your personal preferences.
Then all of your data
runs through our algorithm,
helping us create
the perfect pillow for you.
Our modular design
allows us to create
over 35 possible
variations
through our innovative
process.
The best part?
While there are
a ton of pillows out there,
nobody else does this.
Even better,
our customers love us.
So, Sharks,
before you hit snooze,
which one of you
will join us
in helping everyone
get a good night's sleep?
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Alright, Sharks,
right in front of you
in those really cool boxes
are your very own
custom Pluto pillows.
Now, we had to do
some research
to figure out
what we should craft for you.
We think these make great
starting‐out points.
So, Mark, word around
the league
is that you prefer
fill pillows over foam pillows,
and you like your pillows
to be really soft.
So we made sure
to craft that for you.
Squishy, squishy, squishy.
‐Nice.
‐I like my pillow squishy.
Daniel, we heard
how important it is
for your sleep products
to be hypoallergenic.
The good news is,
all of our pillows are.
We crafted a pillow for you
that's both light and soft.
Mr. Wonderful,
we heard that you prefer
fill pillows
over foam pillows,
so we made one for you
that's just that,
but one
that never flattens.
Lori, you tend to
heat up at night
and you like more of
a medium firmness level.
And lastly, Robert,
lucky you,
you're exactly the same
as Mr. Wonderful.
Both of you love thick,
plushy, fill pillows.
Yours is a quilted cover
while Kevin's is a smooth.
So, Sharks,
enjoy your out‐of‐this‐world
Pluto pillow.
Susana, I have a question.
I always assumed
that there was actually
a better pillow for everyone.
Are you saying that
that's not the case,
that really, truly, there is no
scientific best for everybody?
There isn't.
So, we take your body stats,
sleep positions,
and preferences,
so we know that,
like, let's say,
if you're a side‐sleeper,
you need that, like,
neck support
for the neck to
shoulder tip ratio,
whereas, like,
a stomach sleeper,
it's better if you sleep
on a flat pillow.
But besides that, we also
have empirical evidence,
we have over 1.5 million
data points
that we take into account,
of, like, what makes
a great pillow for you.
What do you mean by those
1.5 million data points?
So, we have an algorithm
on our site
that, every time anyone
goes on our website,
orders a pillow,
we store this information,
and then we look
at other people
who answer similarly
to that person.
And then we see, like,
exactly what kind of pillow
would be best for them
with this data point.
And this has actually led to
a very low return rate
compared to
the industry average.
The industry average
is 12.95%,
while ours is sub‐8%,
and we did this in two years.
Break down the numbers for me.
2018, 197K
when we first started.
2019, 473K.
And this year so far
is 490K.
‐There you go!
‐Wow.
What's the average
sales price?
We sell our
standard sizes for $95.
How are you manufacturing?
So, how this works is,
if you guys open up
your pillows,
inside, there's
actually a foam core,
and it's surrounded by
a plush outer cover.
So there's these
two main parts,
and through
our questionnaire,
when it goes through
our algorithm,
the computer actually
decides, like,
"Hey, this person needs this
foam with that plush cover."
So someone's
in the facility picking,
putting it together,
and packing.
Yeah, they just pick it,
put it together, and box it.
Just two components
and variations
of those two components?
Yeah, two components make
over 35 variations
that feel really different.
One pillow,
you sell it at $95.
Yes.
And then what does it
cost you,
including fulfillment?
And what is your ‐‐
what do you have left?
So, $95 ‐‐
$18 shipping,
and it cost us $25 to $30
to make the pillow.
So $43.
So you only have
about 50% margin.
Yes, so with that,
it's $50 to $60,
just cost of goods sold.
So that's not a big ratio
difference. Normally, there is.
It sounds like your gross margin
structure is not so good.
Is there a reason why?
Because no matter
how much you grow,
if your gross margin
out the gate is bad,
you're just compounding
the problems.
Why are your gross margins
not healthier?
Yeah, and that's why ‐‐
Like, if we could have
a bigger‐size warehouse
to order more materials,
we could get that down
to $20 to $25
instead of $25 to $30.
You're talking about
a few dollars.
Like, $18 of
your cost is shipping.
Right.
Tell me a little bit
about the back‐end operations.
How big is the team?
So, before this year,
it was actually just us two.
We boxed every pillow.
We answered all the questions.
We made everything.
You guys did all the boxing
in the warehouse?
Yeah. All of it.
All the boxing
in the warehouse.
And then
we talked to press.
Okay. And now?
And now we hired
two pillow‐builders.
[ Chuckles ]
Pillow‐builders.
Yeah.
And we have someone
who is full‐time
on customer service.
I want to share with you
a few things, my thoughts.
While you're picking
something smart,
because pillows are great
and everybody needs pillows,
it's also an extremely
competitive space,
and I just think
the combination of that
along with your valuation,
it's just not the right
investment for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you very much,
Lori. Yes.
Thank you, Lori.
Herjavec: Guys, you guys
are super impressive.
I think Lori makes
a really good point
about how competitive
that industry is.
Yes, but nobody does
what we're doing,
in terms of taking
body stats, sleep positions,
and preferences
into account.
And we have
a utility patent pending.
We have over
1.5 million data points.
You have a utility patent
pending on what?
Yes.
On the way we make the pillows
combined with the algorithm.
[ Chuckles ] Really?
And we have over 1.5 million
data points
that no other company has,
in terms of, like, evidence on
what makes a good pillow.
We did all the hard work
already, right?
We already established
the brand.
You actually haven't.
We already created
a product.
Guys, you haven't.
So, here.
I'm guessing you're using
machine learning,
'cause it's linear, right?
Yeah.
1.5 million data points
is nothing.
But you actually have
kind of dropped the ball,
and I can tell by your answers,
because the better approach
is to say,
"Based off my data points,
including my orders,
I can build in anticipation
of what will be ordered
and where they'll be
ordered from,"
'cause you already know,
based off your
machine learning algorithms,
how many orders
are going to take place
from this part of the country,
that part of the country,
this part of the country,
right?
I'm saying all this because
I don't think
you've gone through
that whole process yet, right?
And I don't think
you're fully aware
of all the things you're going
to have to go through yet
to get there.
So for those reasons, I'm out.
I love pillows.
I'm obsessive about pillows,
but, you know,
this word of "algorithm."
Everybody talks about
how they have an algorithm,
and I'm not 100% sure that
nobody else can do that.
I don't think this is
where I'm gonna sleep
comfortably, so I'm out.
Thank you very much,
Daniel.
Thank you, Daniel.
If this had been for a lower
amount of capital risk,
I would have probably done it
just for the talent,
but you guys are too small
for 8 million bucks.
I'm out.
Thank you, Kevin.
Herjavec: I have to tell you,
when you came out here
and you started talking
about pillows,
I was bored out of my mind.
I couldn't have been
less interested,
but you sold me.
And I think there's
a couple of big problems.
To Mark's point, your algorithm,
it's not predictive.
You've got to know what the
potential orders are gonna be
before you get them,
and I think
you'll start getting that
once you get the volume.
Yeah.
But come on!
Who up here knew everything
about their business
and didn't make those mistakes?
So at the end of the day,
it's not about
the mistakes you're making,
it's about my confidence in
your ability to overcome them.
And you've sold me on that.
So I like it all.
Hate the valuation.
Don't let that
get in your way, Robert.
So I was being quiet
with my own algorithm
and saying, "What number would
make me feel comfortable"...
‐Here it comes. [ Laughs ]
‐..."sleeping at night?"
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out,
but Robert is interested
in Kevin and Susana's
custom‐built pillow company,
Pluto.
"What number would make me
feel comfortable"...
‐Here it comes. [ Laughs ]
‐..."sleeping at night?"
So, you're looking for
$400,000 for 5%.
I'm thinking $400,000...
for 20%.
Eeh, Chihuahua, caramba!
It's aggressive, but your ask
was very aggressive.
It's an amount that I feel
comfortable with,
but I think
it's one of those things.
You won't need more money.
You're gonna need
more expertise
and more ways
to get out there faster.
$400,000 for 20%.
It's an offer.
You've got
a "Shark Tank" offer.
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
Go. Just go. 10.
I think that's just
a little bit high.
Would you be able to go down
to 9% for $400,000?
No, I'm not gonna
come down that much.
I mean, would I go down
to 19, 19.5,
some marginal amount?
Sure, maybe,
if you could convince me.
But I think it's a lot of money.
It really is.
Okay.
And it's a lot of my time.
And I do think
you're one of these investments
we're gonna look back on
and say,
"Wow.
Pluto went to the moon."
That's true.
I think 19 is just
a little bit too much.
We've seen
triple‐digit growth
year over year
since we started,
and we feel like
there's not really much
in our way to keep growing.
We do want
some expertise.
Cuban:
Stick to your guns, guys.
Stick to your guns.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong
with sticking to your guns.
I disagree, guys.
He could help you a lot.
Cuban:
Stick to your guns, guys.
Herjavec: Everything for me
is a matter
of investment and risk,
and I think at 20%,
I'm deeply invested.
What do you want to do?
Let's shoot for the stars!
Thank you so much
for the offer, Robert,
but I think 19%, 20% is just
a little bit too much.
I think we can't really
go more than 10%
for $400,000.
I‐I can't get there.
Okay.
Thank you, Robert.
Thank you.
Lubetzky: Guys, good luck.
Thank you so much.
Congrats, guys,
and good luck.
Thank you.
Well done.
Greiner: Good luck, guys.
Thank you very much, guys.
Thank you.
While we're so flattered
by Robert's offer,
we felt we were worth way
more than what he was offering,
and we feel that we could still
grow this company ourselves.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 11,
farm owner Katey Jo Evans
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for The Frozen Farmer,
ice creams and sorbets
made with imperfect produce.
Greiner: I will give you
the money
if we can land
a major national chain.
Narrator:
Let's see what she's doing now.
Evans:
Airing in March of 2020
during the height
of the pandemic
put us in a really tough spot.
We had built an incredible
amount of inventory up,
anticipating increased sales,
but we couldn't get the product
from our warehouse
to the grocery store,
so we launched online sales
of our ice cream
and shipped directly
to our customers' doorsteps.
We pivoted our farm creamery
to help our community
and supplied everyday
essential goods
out of our drive‐thru window,
and we donated pints
to local hospital workers,
police stations,
and fire departments
to thank them for their service.
What happened next
was incredible.
A Walmart buyer was
interested in the product line.
I was able to close the deal
with more than 4,300
Walmart locations nationwide.
When I pitched on "Shark Tank,"
I brought with me
our "nice cream."
We've since changed
the name to "Frobert."
It's a blend of our traditional
ice cream and sorbet,
reducing the fat
and calorie content
without sacrificing
flavor or creaminess.
Frobert is entirely new
to the category.
There's nothing on the shelf
like it.
Now we're in more than
8,000 stores,
including Giant Foods,
Stop N Shop,
and every Kroger location
nationwide.
The year I pitched
to the Sharks,
my business had done
$310,000 in sales.
Now, just nine months
since "Shark Tank,"
I'm nearing $1 million in sales
with $15 million
in committed purchase orders.
On the "Shark Tank,"
I gave you a challenge,
and you not only got into
one major retailer nationwide,
you got into four.
I love Frozen Farmer's mission.
I love that they use
unloved fruit
that's delicious,
just not as pretty,
and I love that Katey Jo
is probably
one of the hardest‐working,
most results‐oriented
entrepreneurs I've ever had.
I'm super proud of you,
and I'm just super excited
for our future.
Aah! [ Laughs ]
Evans:
There's been so many times
that we could have given up
and, quite honestly,
so many times
that maybe we even wanted to.
But we knew in our hearts
that The Frozen Farmer
was a continuation
of our family's legacy,
and the mission
of reducing food waste
is so important to us.
We're creating a better world
one pint at a time,
and that's something, for us,
that makes The Frozen Farmer
so much sweeter.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a new
iteration of a favorite sport.
♪♪
[ Loud clatter ]
Whoa!
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Alex van Alen.
And I'm John Pruellage.
We're from
Ipswich, Massachusetts,
and we're here
seeking $300,000
for 10% of our company,
Fling Golf.
Sharks, golf courses
have a big problem.
Over 1,800 of them have
closed in the last decade,
and the average golfer
gets older every year.
You see, young people,
they just think
that golf is too expensive,
it's too hard to learn,
there's too many clubs,
takes too long,
and many
just find it boring.
Well, we've developed
the antidote for boring.
It's called
Fling Golf.
It's the cool, athletic
alternative to regular golf.
[ Chuckles ]
You play Fling Golf with
a regular golf ball,
but instead of lugging
around a set of clubs
and hitting the ball,
you're using
a single fling stick
to throw
the golf ball...
Oh, my God.
...and shoot every kind of shot
from tee to hole.
Yeah, you can take long shots,
flop shots,
bump and runs,
and on the green...
The color of money.
...you can even
use it to putt.
Most people can learn to play
within 10 minutes.
Some are even out there
bombing it 250 yards.
So just like snowboarders
are welcome on ski resorts,
Fling Golf can be played right
alongside traditional golf.
The best part is,
courses don't need
to make any changes at all.
They just let
the people play.
Fling Golf
has already been played
on over
1,000 golf courses.
Wow.
So, we've developed
an entirely new product,
a new sport embraced by
a younger generation
and accepted by golf courses
across the globe.
Who wants to go on
the fling of their lifetime
and help us scale up
the future of the fairway?
Alright.
Who wants to come on up?
I'll try it out.
I don't know
anything about golf.
It's not golf.
Cuban:
Wait, hold on.
[ Chuckles ]
Lubetzky: You all should do
what Mark's doing.
Aim that way.
Daniel, you're
throwing it this way?
Yeah, you might want to
really go away.
Let me show you. What you do is,
you hold it back here,
you drop it
way down your back,
then put your other hand up,
and then ‐‐
There you go! Nice.
There you go!
So, guys, you've invented
lacrosse on the golf course.
Right. Basically
lacrosse and golf.
And that was sort of
my background.
Gotcha.
Alright, so, you drop it
way down your back...
‐Yeah! You looked nice.
‐It's starting to feel good.
Nice! Yeah!
Very cool.
Just a few shots.
O'Leary: Alright, guys, look.
I am a member of the golf club.
No chance in Hell
are they gonna let anybody run
around with a lacrosse racket.
Zero!
[ Laughs ]
No, they do.
It's been played at
the country club in Brookline.
It's like snowboarding
and skiing.
We're getting into
the golf courses.
But ultimately,
it's gonna be like
there's no reason not to.
But the golf gods would strike
you dead with that thing.
We don't care.
Pruellage: Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Wait.
I have a question.
Yeah!
Best answer ever!
We don't care.
We're not golf.
Let's say you get good.
You can go far and straight.
But then when you get to
the green, what happens?
It turns into
a golf club.
You can do
a flop shot.
Yeah?
You can do
a bump and run.
Hang on. This is your only club?
This is your putter...
Greiner: It's your one club.
That's it.
It's the whole thing.
Herjavec: ...this is
your chipping wedge.
Do everything with it.
This is the one thing
that might get me
to a golf course.
But, I mean, you could hurt
somebody if you hit them.
Yeah.
Herjavec: Yes.
This is way more accurate
than golf.
How many courses
have you sold this to?
A set of clubs.
Like, that's a good indication.
About 300.
So, what's the model?
How does it work?
We sell to both golf courses
and the consumer.
We focused a lot in the last
few years on the golf courses.
We want that acceptance.
We want people to know
that if they buy
one of these things from us,
they can go out
on any golf course and play.
Longer‐term,
the focus is really
gonna be the consumer.
How are you gonna get
the golf course to, like,
educate anybody playing
about the stick?
Van Alen:
The specific golf courses
that are doing well with it
are, like, resorts.
They're able to advertise
to people
that aren't just the people
coming in to play golf.
When people arrive, they'll say,
"Hey, bring your family.
Even if you're a golfer,
bring your kids.
We'll give them
a Fling stick,
and they can go out with you
and play golf."
Herjavec: So, guys,
I did an investment
in a company
called Bad Birdie.
They're the cool golf shirts.
COVID hits ‐‐
I'm thinking their business
is going to die.
Like, it's just
gonna go nowhere.
Golf is on fire.
Because of
the distance.
‐It's one of the only things.
‐It's one of the few things
you can actually do outside.
They're gonna do
$3.5 million this year.
Right.
So you're definitely on‐trend.
What I'm struggling with is,
how do you capture
a customer base?
The focus has been
on golf courses,
but we're selling
as much to consumers.
Actually,
in terms of numbers,
we're selling more to consumers
than we are on the golf course.
How much?
What did you sell last year?
Last year,
we sold $142,000.
Good for you.
$140,000.
What about this year?
We're $142,000
through July.
So what's one club
cost you to make,
and what do you
sell it for?
They range from $119
to the one you're
holding there is $179.
And for cost to make,
this one's about $25.
That one's about $35.
Your valuation seems
really out of whack.
Like, you're asking
for more than
10 times revenue valuation.
Can you walk us through
how you came up
with that delusional valuation?
[ Sharks laugh ]
Herjavec:
Wow, you're really sitting
next to Kevin a lot, Daniel.
We were on set for about
$400,000 this year,
and then COVID hit,
that slowed us down.
But according to Robert, COVID
should be helping you out.
It seems like it's not.
Well, it slowed us down big‐time
for March and April.
Look, at the end of the day,
if you're just taking this
as a commodity product
and doing a multiple
off of revenue,
yeah, you're not gonna
get there on that.
But what we've
built here
and a lot of what goes
into that valuation
is the foundation
we've built ‐‐
all the product development,
the IP, the patents.
So then how much have you guys
raised or invested?
We've raised about ‐‐
about $2 million.
There you go. That's why
the valuation's so high.
Greiner: Wow.
Herjavec: Where did you
raise that from?
You've raised $2 million?
Did I hear that right?
One and a half
is actually from us.
You put your own money in?
Damn!
Wow.
Look, I like
the idea, guys,
but it's very difficult
to scale a new sport,
as you know, right?
Yes.
And inevitably,
it takes a purse.
If your price range is
from $100 to $179
and you did $140,000
last year,
you're looking at about
1,400 clubs, right?
And that's just not enough
traction for me to get excited.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Guys, I love innovation
and ‐‐ and new ideas,
but I keep thinking about
the lack of precision ‐‐
these balls, like
[Chuckling] flying all around.
And your valuation,
I do have to say,
I don't think is commensurate
to where you're at right now.
I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you.
Just 'cause you say
it's worth $3 million,
that doesn't mean anything.
It can't be worth
3 million bucks,
'cause you don't have
any cash flow
to sustain that valuation.
If you look at
what snowboarding did ‐‐
and we model
a lot off of what happened
in the 1970s, '80s,
with snowboarding ‐‐
It took a long time before ‐‐
and then it went geometric.
I get it, but I don't think
you're at that
trajectory right now.
And I didn't think it was
poo‐poo on a stick
until I heard the sales.
Now I really think
it's poo‐poo on a stick.
So no, absolutely not.
I'm out.
♪♪
Alex and John,
this is my thoughts.
KIND bars are sold
in almost every single course
in America.
There's several golfers
that wear KIND colors
because they love it so much.
I can introduce you
to a lot of golfers.
to golf courses.
This is going to be
a huge amount of work,
so I will do the deal
at 33% for the $300,000.
You are so greedy.
Alright, guys, look ‐‐
I love golf.
I belong to a bunch of clubs.
Here's what I can do for you ‐‐
I can point you.
Yeah.
Just like Bad Birdie.
It's not like I go there
and do their books every day,
but we talk regularly.
He has a problem, he says,
"Do I go left? Do I go right?"
That's what you need.
What I need to know is,
are you gonna hustle?
This is all about hustle,
and, I mean,
we're gonna do ‐‐
I'm confident we're doing,
with or without you,
a million dollars
in sales next year.
I've drained
my finances.
I need this. I absolutely
need this. I'm in.
I'll give you the $300,000,
but I want to be
a one‐third partner.
I'll take the risk with you.
I can help you with this thing.
Same offer as Daniel?
Same offer
as Daniel.
But it only took him
an hour longer to make it.
Okay, so, guys ‐‐
I think you ought to talk to
them, because you just devalued
all the money that
they've invested significantly.
I did, but again, you know,
it's either gonna go big
or it's not.
You've got to pick your Shark.
What are you gonna do?
And you can counter.
[ Whispering ] Yeah,
$300,000 for 20?
[ Both whispering indistinctly ]
How about $300,000
for 20%, either of you?
I'll do $300,000 for 25%,
and it goes away in 5...
4...3...2...
Take it.
...1.
‐Done.
‐Whoo!
‐Good deal.
Alright.
Guys, what Robert said
is true ‐‐
you guys need to stay
in the fight and be hungry,
because it's gonna take
a lot longer ‐‐
You have never met someone
who's gonna hustle more than us.
Congratulations, guys.
Congratulations.
I can't believe it.
Greiner: Congrats.
‐Alright.
‐[ Chuckles ]
That was awesome.
Pruellage: Daniel's got
nothing to worry about.
We are committed,
and we are all in on this.
We're gonna see this
to the end,
and we know it's gonna be
a huge sport.
Very often, you have to
step down to get the poop,
but not anymore.
[ Laughs ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a better way to grill
in an unlikely place.
♪♪
Hey there, Sharks.
My name's
Mike Bashawaty.
And I'm Jeremy Quillico.
We're from
Plymouth, Michigan,
and we're here
seeking $200,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in our company.
Sharks, let me
paint you a picture.
It's sweet summertime.
You're on the lake
with your best friends,
knocking back
a cold one
and enjoying
the good vibes.
Everything is just perfect,
until ‐‐
Both: [ Gasp ]
Hunger strikes!
Now, there is nothing better
than a hot, juicy cheeseburger
to fulfill that craving
and keep the party going.
And wouldn't it be crazy if you
could grill up some food
without ever having
to leave the water?
Well, Sharks, these guys
were just crazy enough
to come up with
a solution.
Introducing
the world's first...
The world's only...
Float'N'Grill!
[ Sharks cheer, laugh ]
Now, you're probably thinking
a grill that floats
on water?
We're thinking...
"Hell, yeah!"
Float'N'Grill is
lightweight, easy to use,
and has tons of features
so you can safely cook
without ever going back to land.
And with our patented design
and unique weight displacement,
you won't have to worry about it
flipping over in the water.
So whether you're
a sandbar fanatic...
Or a lazy‐river goer...
Float'N'Grill
has got you covered.
Be the envy of your friends
with this innovative product
and be the talk
of the lake.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to get in on the action
while the grill's
still hot?
Were you guys on, like,
Instagram just recently?
Oh!
We were on ‐‐
We had a post back in 2018
that went viral,
and it started catching traction
again just a few weeks ago.
Yeah, 'cause I saw it again,
the dude going down the ‐‐
That's me.
[ Laughing ] That's you.
Well, tell us about it.
What was it?
We kind of threw it
out there on a Facebook page.
In 72 hours,
we hit 4.7 million people.
Wow.
And this thing
just exploded.
But what was in the video?
It was just
hysterical.
So you're just, like,
floating in the water,
and it's floating
next to you?
Yeah, and you're, like,
flipping a burger or something?
Yeah.
How did you
come up with this?
I bought a 16‐foot
jet boat,
started getting acclimated
with sandbar life.
and I was like,
"Okay."
Love jet boats.
Great time.
Sandbar life.
Well, sandbar life,
you're there for 6 to 8 hours,
and who wants to eat
a cold, soggy sub?
Then how does that work?
What is the heat source?
Yep, so, right here, you use
a 1‐pound propane tank.
We have
a remote mounting hose.
And is the base solid,
or do I have to blow it up?
The base is HDPE plastic,
food‐grade.
The grill actually has a
1,200 BTU burner, which is huge.
I can fit eight burgers
on that grill.
Cuban: Eight burgers?
Greiner: Eight burgers.
So, wait, have we talked about
what you sell it for
and what it costs
and how many you've sold?
Oh, we can
get into that, too.
Yeah.
Let's go!
Let's go for it!
So, right now, right now,
it retails for $229.
‐Okay.
Our cost of goods on this
is $126.88.
That's kind of
expensive.
But hang on. Hang on.
That is expensive, but we give
the customer free shipping,
so we put that
into our cost of goods.
Okay, that's fine.
It's still cost of good, right?
Yeah. That's an average number
that we put in there.
So now,
what is your total sales?
So, our total gross sales
for this year
are $19,400.
What?
Sharks: Ohh!
Yeah. Hey, hey.
♪ Wah‐wah‐wah‐wah ♪
That is with zero dollars
on marketing.
We have not marketed
this product.
That is all organic.
Jeremy, did you say 19?
$19,000.
We just launched
a year and a half ago.
Ohhhh!
Don't give me
that "Ohhhh"!
A year and a half ago?
That's like two years ‐‐
I don't want to hear it.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
That is not ‐‐ Listen.
Ohh.
With zero marketing ‐‐
That's not even
100 units!
Listen, listen,
listen, listen.
It's $199, which he
neglected to mention.
Listen.
The sandbar community
has rejected you.
No!
Has rejected you.
Do you go to
the sandbar?
Do you spend time at
the sandbar, Mr. Wonderful?
All I know is, nobody's
using this in the sandbar.
Oh, they are.
Oh, my God.
They are.
They are loving it.
Hey, it didn't go viral
for no reason.
It didn't go viral
Yeah, but then out of
those 4 million views,
I would have expected
a little bit higher conversion.
I can explain that.
Listen, listen, listen.
There's more to the story.
We went viral
back in 2018.
We didn't have anything
to sell at that time,
because we didn't
have it in place.
Yeah.
I hate it when
that happens.
Oh, me too.
We didn't have an established
manufacturer for the grill.
Guys, guys, can I ‐‐
I just want to step on
one thing for a second,
because it's important.
You want 20%.
[ Chuckling ] That imputes ‐‐
and I'm trying to be serious ‐‐
Yep.
...a million‐dollar valuation.
Yes.
With basically no one
in the sandbar community
gives a poo‐poo
about this thing.
No one knows about it, really.
But that's
where you're wrong.
Are you in
the sandbar community?
I am the sandbar community.
You haven't seen him
in his Speedo on his speedboat?
Listen. The word out on the
street within the community is
nobody gives a poo‐poo
about this thing.
That's wrong.
You're completely wrong.
They're not buying it!
You're completely wrong
about that,
because everybody
that sees it ‐‐
Well, how come
there's no sales?
99% of those reactions on
that viral post were positive.
No, and the best part is, is we
have accessories coming out,
which we have
3‐D renderings for.
This isn't even
in the works right now.
You have accessories?
You haven't sold any yet!
I'm just saying.
[ Laughter ]
Lubetzky: I'm friends with
the guys from Weber Grills.
‐Okay.
I'm very close with them.
Yep.
Is there something that you
could either license to them,
or is there a reason why they
couldn't do that themselves?
Why does your patent cover it?
We, in the ‐‐
So, the first claim
on our patent
is a floating apparatus
that supports a cooking element
for cooking purposes.
Cuban: Good for you.
That's very broad.
It's very broad.
Yes.
I don't know if you're familiar
with Webers ‐‐
probably the foremost
grill company in the U. S.
‐Yep.
‐Yes.
I'll set up
the meeting for you,
and we will license this
to them,
either sell them the patent
or license it.
I'll give you $200,000 for 50%.
$200,000 for 15%?
‐Bam!
‐5‐0.
‐Oh.
Lubetzky: 5‐0. You can counter.
O'Leary: 50. Half.
Yeah, I mean ‐‐
Half the community.
Yeah.
Herjavec: Wow.
You just said that they
sold $19,000 in sales.
Yeah.
So, we respect that offer,
but honestly,
we can't go that high.
What's your counter?
My counteroffer,
right off the bat,
is we believe
in this product so much,
I'm not opposed to
a partial loan.
I would do a $100,000 loan
at 7% interest rate,
$100,000 investment
for 15% to 20%.
Well, let's say 20%
to be fair.
And we'll pay you
$2 per unit sold
'til your loan money
is paid back.
Well, Mikey is a Shark!
I'm just coming in!
Let's go!
‐You're a Shark, baby!
He's a numbers guy!
He is there! Let's do it!
You guys, at $2 a unit,
he will die of old age
before he gets his loan back.
[ Laughs ]
Any other offers,
guys?
Not a chance in Hell.
I'm out, just ‐‐
I'm out.
Quillico:
Yeah, fair enough.
I truly, unfortunately,
with your valuation
and what your sales were ‐‐
I'm sorry, I'm out.
I love you guys.
I mean, I love the entire story.
Except the $19,000 in sales.
We understand ‐‐
It all falls apart on that.
We understand that, but those
are the numbers, unfortunately,
and that's why we're here.
Guys, you have an offer
here that might go away.
Guys, don't let
this opportunity float away.
The $19,000 is
a warning for all of us.
Yep. It is.
It is.
I'm jumping in because
I like your patent ‐‐
it is a strong patent ‐‐
and because you guys
are fun.
So I'm jumping in
and giving you the $200,000
for 50%, equal partners,
because guess what,
my team is gonna
work on this full‐time
to make it work.
We can't do 50%.
So, right now...
We have two
other investors.
We do have
two other investors, okay?
Yeah.
‐What do they own?
‐What do you guys own?
They own 30% ‐‐
10% and 20%.
And you guys own 70%?
Yes.
Company was valued at
$300,000 at that point.
Alright.
What are you gonna do?
I mean, it sounds like
we're very far apart.
I mean, we are.
Can we negotiate on anything
with the licensing deal,
where you make
"X" amount of dollars
on the licensing deal
on top of having
the 22.5% in the company?
So your maximum that you're
willing to sell me is what?
22.5% is
what we can sell.
That's ‐‐ yeah.
Here's my offer ‐‐
the $100,000 investment
for 22.5%,
$100,000 loan at 7%.
We're gonna remove
the $2 per unit.
You don't need to do that.
Okay.
And 50% of any licensing
that I help you get.
You okay with that?
♪♪
You've got a deal.
That deal just got better,
didn't it, Mikey? [ Laughs ]
Dude. Ahhh!
Cuban: Congratulations, guys.
Good luck.
Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Take care, you guys.
‐Float out of here.
Whew.
Dude.
I cannot ‐‐
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, my God.
Oh, my goodness.
That was nuts.
We got a deal
with Daniel Lubetzky.
A billionaire.
That's ‐‐ That's insane.
That is insane.
How much is that?
That's a lot of money.
A billion. Oh, man.
I don't ‐‐ Whoo!
Yeah.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an accessory
that makes shoes
more functional.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Jamie Montz.
And I'm David Montz from
beautiful Boise, Idaho,
and we're the duo behind
The Original Stretchlace.
We're here today
seeking $100,000
for 15% equity
in our company.
We have created
a must‐have product
to enhance the fit, function,
and fashion of tie shoes.
Traditional laces
are restrictive.
You have to tie them
every day,
sometimes
multiple times a day,
and on top of that,
they're bo‐ring.
Give your shoes
an affordable lace‐over
with The Original
Stretchlace.
The Original Stretchlace
is a stretchy lace
that elevates
the function of your shoe
by turning your tie shoes
into slip‐ons.
Let's see if David can slip
into his boots
and back into his sneakers
in less than 10 seconds.
[ Exhales sharply ]
David, are you ready?
Ready.
Sharks, will you help me
give him a countdown?
Together: 10...9...8...
7...6...5...
4...3...2...1.
2 1/2!
Aah!
Slowing down in your
old age, David.
Too fast.
That was easy, right?
It was easy.
It was pretty easy.
10 seconds isn't a lot of time.
Our unique material
has a slight texture
to keep your shoelaces tied,
while providing
a firm but comfortable grip
on your feet.
So, Sharks, don't shoelace ‐‐
Stretchlace.
[ Chuckles ]
Are you ready to
expand with us?
‐Ha.
‐Ra‐ra‐ra‐ra.
David: We have some
samples for you.
Herjavec: So, how does it work,
Jamie?
I take it out,
and I put them in?
Yep, you just lace them
like standard laces.
Leave a little bit of room
at the top,
tie them, and then
you just slip your shoes on.
And you're saying
because they stretch,
you can just slide in and out?
And that's the...
Exactly.
Oh, it works!
It's very easy to do.
Oh, my gosh.
It really works.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah. It works.
How much do you sell them for?
How much do they cost?
$9.99 to $13.99,
and they cost anywhere
from $1.49 to $2.14.
Well, a great margin.
And would I find your product
on the country's largest
online retailer?
You would.
And would I find it
on your website, as well?
Yes.
Anywhere in retail?
We are only
going after online.
Break down
the numbers for me.
Last year was $221,000.
This year, we're doing
$165,000.
However, there's
a little story to tell.
So, I left my job
in July,
and we started to see this
really nice, healthy
uptick in growth.
Then coronavirus
hit the States,
and we saw
a slow decrease.
Then the countries
that I supply from
were also hit
by coronavirus,
so we didn't have
any inventory.
And are you in
the company, too?
No, so, I help
keep the lights on.
I have a full‐time job.
I'm in technology.
I've been 22 years
in technology.
You're a couple?
Yeah, we're
husband and wife.
Married.
You know, providing
financially for the family.
I'm working full‐time,
and we have three kids,
which is a lot.
So I do everything I can
when I get home or off work,
to give her the bandwidth,
'cause she works tirelessly.
This woman has put so much sweat
equity into this business,
I can't even
measure it.
How did you
come up with this?
Why I started
the company?
I have three boys,
and getting ready
in the mornings was crazy.
I was tying
three pairs of shoes,
and I was
thinking to myself,
"What are they walking
through at school
that I'm touching these
every morning?"
And it just kind of
ruined my day.
Ew.
I went to the market
to see what was available,
and I have a 20‐year
background in e‐commerce.
I kind of know
the lay of the land,
in terms of product.
And so when I looked
at the market,
I found product
with locks or clips,
and I have three kids.
They're gonna be rough
and they're gonna break them
and they're gonna
lose the clips,
and it's gonna be a mess.
So there were no
stretchy laces that tied in...
No. There weren't.
Nope.
Herjavec: How long ago
was that, Jamie?
That was three years,
a little over three years ago.
And just last July,
I left working for
another company to pursue this.
Good for you.
What was your job
at the other company?
I was managing
an Amazon business
that was about
$35 million in revenue
in the health and beauty
category for that company.
You've managed
a $35 million brand
and then said, "Hey,
I can take those skills
to do it for myself."
So now what I'd like to see is,
how have you applied that?
Because the numbers,
for a person that has
20 years of experience
and that run a $35 million
business,
they're not...amazing.
When we first launched
the business,
I was working full‐time.
So I have been doing this
on nights and weekends,
and really,
I really just left my job,
working full‐time, in July.
I would say something
that I think I'm super proud of
is the fact that we got on to
the largest e‐tailer, Amazon,
and we're able to take
a significant market share
from those other brands
that have been around
a lot longer than we have.
I think I did better in terms
of becoming an expert
on how to grow this business
on that platform.
When I developed
this product,
we researched what was
going on on Amazon
in terms of the search, the
keyword volume, the relevancy.
When somebody looks for
"stretch lace,"
knowing the Amazon algorithm,
knowing that they're searching
for laces, stretch, elastic,
and those titles
were in our keywords.
‐Smart.
‐Right.
She, in my eyes,
has a PhD in Amazon.
Jamie, I'm struggling.
You are a 20‐year
Amazon goddess
selling a $13 shoelace.
Ugh. I'm out.
Okay, guys, look, no disrespect
for you when I say this ‐‐
you are shoelace cockroaches.
[ Laughs ]
I can't work with you.
I'm out.
Jamie, I somewhat disagree
that necessarily, the shoelace
is the wrong vehicle.
But I am actually concerned
about you as an entrepreneur.
Maybe you're a great manager,
but do you have that ability
to be resourceful
[Sniffs]
to be a hungry hunter,
to observe
and to turn and twist?
I can give you
a couple ‐‐
I don't see that
entrepreneurial zeal,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Greiner: I can tell.
I mean, you have
that fire, right?
You are an inventor,
entrepreneur.
There are bumps in the road.
Right.
And you're
doing a great job,
and so I think
you're gonna get there.
I just don't think this is
the right product for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Oh. Sorry to
hear that, Lori.
Cuban: You know, guys,
I think you're better
without an investor right now.
If you had an investor,
you go from just, "What can I do
on Amazon on my time?"
Okay, maybe I can
get this done."
As a family,
you can get this done.
To, "Okay, Mark time, too,"
and obligations there.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
‐Good luck, guys.
Congratulations.
‐Good luck.
Thank you.
Herjavec: Hey, Jamie.
I got to believe there's more
in you than shoelaces,
and I think you can actually
help us sell online
with some of our other
businesses,
'cause we can all
do better with that.
And I think there's
unlocked potential within you
to do different things.
I'll make you an offer.
Are you nuts?
♪♪
Narrator:
All five Sharks are out,
but Robert has had
a change of heart,
seeing the untapped potential
in Jamie as an entrepreneur.
I'll make you an offer.
Are you nuts?
[ Both chuckle ]
I'll give you ‐‐
You might be crying for
a different reason in a minute.
[ Laughs ]
Look, it's an
investment in you,
to unlock the potential
within you.
I'll give you
the $100,000 for 33%.
Ohhh!
Now cry.
If that don't make you cry,
I don't know what will.
Hang on.
Let me ‐‐ Let me explain.
I don't think
it's a Sharky offer.
You're gonna help me.
I'm gonna help you.
You don't need an investor
if that's all you're ever
gonna do is shoelaces.
But I got to tell you,
as you're talking,
I think you have dreams
bigger than this.
Okay.
Cuban: You're allowed
to counter.
And?
What do you want to
counter with?
Um...
[ Whispering ]
25? Okay.
20, 25.
[ Normal voice ]
Would you accept 25%?
I...
We're nickel‐and‐diming
each other.
If you believe in
the vision that I see in you...
I want to stick to the 33%.
I‐I just think
we're gonna do great things.
I really think you're going to
help all our entrepreneurs,
and I think I'm really
gonna help you guys.
Guys, you have no reason
to be desperate.
Oh, it's ‐‐
No, no, no, don't ‐‐
33% is a big chunk.
No, no, no.
Hang on a sec, Mark.
With all due respect,
I don't think they're desperate
for a moment.
And don't imply that my offer
implied they're desperate.
I'm just saying, 33%.
I believe in them.
$100,000 for 33%.
No desperation.
I'm just saying.
So you're saying that
you're not really interested
in the shoelaces, but ‐‐
Herjavec: No, no, I believe
in the shoelaces.
Okay.
Don't get me wrong.
Let's get that to $3 million.
But while we're getting there,
let's unlock the potential
of this incredible woman
and figure out
what the next product is.
Let's do both.
$100,000, 33%.
What do you think?
[ Sighs ]
I don't know.
30?
Should we ask?
Yeah.
Okay,
would you take 30?
I will take 30.
You have a deal.
Yes!
High five!
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Virtual hug! Virtual hug!
‐Virtual hug.
‐Congrats.
‐Air hugs.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
♪♪
Amazing!
Oh, my God.
It feels so wonderful
to have gotten
a deal with Robert.
It's crazy.
I don't know what ‐‐
What just happened?
Honestly, I don't
know what happened.
What just happened?
It was, like,
everybody was falling out,
then all of a sudden...
Did we just, like,
time travel?
What did you see that would
change your mind?
You bought a
cockroach shoe business.
Kevin. Kevin.
You may not realize this,
but to get great people,
sometimes
you have to pay them.
You are going to make
hundreds of dollars.
[ Laughs ]
Hundreds of dollars.
♪♪